this is kigo an AI powered guide
designed to help all students learn
conmigo is not just for students
teachers can use conmigo too by toggling
from the student mode to teacher mode in
any course and teachers can always
access kigo by selecting the AI
activities button located at the top of
the teacher dashboard kigo has many
exciting features that support teachers
and this video will showcase ways
teachers can use conmigo to create
engaging lesson plans to help support
their students first I'm going to go to
the course that I'm working from I'd
like to create a lesson plan from the
digital sat reading and writing course
that I'm teaching with my students our
next unit is going to be on central idea
and details so I'm going to select that
and once there it shows me all of the
different options that are in there
there's an article some videos as well
as an exercise this is where I need con
Migo's help once I select con Migo's
button kigo will give me different
options that it can help with such as
giving me a lesson summary or helping me
prep for a quiz I would love K Migo's
help with writing a lesson plan so I'm
going to select
that and as soon as I select that button
conmigo starts
working let's take a look at the lesson
plan that K Migo's created for me K
Migo's given me the learning objectives
for the lesson plan
con Migos also created learning
activities for me actually con Migos
created three different learning
activities for me here's an activity on
identifying Central ID and details
here's a 20 minute activity this one's a
20 minute activity this one's a
10-minute activity these are
great Kiko's also created exit ticket
questions for me that I can use with my
students kigos included the key
terms kigo also included the resources
that I'm going to need to help support
my students with this lesson wow kigo is
also included prerequisite videos that I
can share with my students to help give
them background knowledge on the
topic as well as other differentiation
options for advanced Learners and
striving
Learners and then finally K Migo's given
me a lesson summary over what we're
going to be doing here's the
introduction activity 1 Activity 2
Activity 3 and then the exit ticket kigo
lets me know that this timeline is a
rough estimate and I may need to adjust
depending on my students progress but
this is so helpful kigo also gives me
the option to export this lesson plan or
I can print the lesson
plan and because kigo is truly my
co-pilot if there's any part of this
lesson plan that I want to change cono
will do it for me no questions asked I
just highlight what I want changed and
conmigo my co-pilot will give me options
and then makes the changes for
me thank you so much kigo this is so
helpful